[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALBERTO REY VILLAVERDE: Virgin
Media 02 is in the tech space.
And basically, what we do
is try to connect the UK.
From our company perspective,
what we are trying to do
is being more innovative.
That's the first thing.
That was the first
task 12 months
ago when we started
in this journey,
and obviously doing that in a
way that was fast to market.
So our delivery times weren't
really where they should be.
So our focus was on
reducing this lead time.
RICHARD HE: So we're
quite ambitious here.
What we want to do is to turn
the Virgin Media 02 business
into a tier one tech company.
So I guess this is the
first step of that journey.
And I just want to emphasize
it's not just about technology.
And also, it's the
technology itself
that affects what people
do and then how they do it.
So I guess it ultimately affects
the culture of the company
as well.
Our solution, I guess, cuts
across the entire Virgin Media
02 state.
We support, obviously,
millions of customers
in the United Kingdom.
And the vision, I guess, is
for any customer-focused data
product is that it doesn't
matter at which part.
All the customer touchpoints
are consistent and attractive.
ALBERTO REY VILLAVERDE:
If you go 12 months ago
in this organization, we had
a four to six-month lead time
to make critical changes
in this algorithm.
And right now, where we
are a couple of weeks ago,
we were doing deployments
in under 60 minutes,
and doing the change, doing the
deployment, doing the testing,
and putting it
live, which is just
basically mind-blowing
for where we were before.
RICHARD HE: I can't thank you
enough, the Google Cloud team.
Specifically, it was the custom
engineering team, Beatrice
in that team, in London.
So not only they helped us
with all of these questions
that we asked.
But also, in many
occasions, they
put us directly in touch with
the product engineering team.
ALBERTO REY VILLAVERDE: We are
just two is here in this award.
It's Richard and I.
But to be honest,
there is a big team of data
engineers, ML engineers, data
scientists, data analysts,
data product managers.
So we have a big team around.
And to be honest, it has
been thanks to everybody.
It's not just, basically,
to one particular person.
So we wouldn't be here as well
if it wasn't because of them
and--
RICHARD HE: Exactly.
I can't agree more.
I think that's really
important, to emphasize
that without that team, that at
the back of that supporting us,
this wouldn't have
been possible at all.
And although we are on the
path or on the tracks of trying
to get to be a tier
one tech company,
but we're still enterprise.
So behind the scenes,
the complexity
is really, really high.
And then, we needed
a lot of support
from the many parts
of the business for us
to achieve this together.
ALBERTO REY VILLAVERDE:
And we're very, very proud
about winning this award.
But at the end of the day,
we are still collaborating.
So it's not something
that has finished.
So I really appreciate
having the team
there by our side day-by-day.
And yeah, very grateful.
[MUSIC PLAYING]